it's time for some serious soul
searching by Nikki Haley and Ronda
santis it's time to step aside and
endorse Trump now not surprisingly that
political advice stoked almost instant
backlash from both the disantis and the
Haley camps but as I tried to say last
night this is nothing personal now few
did more to Showcase Ronda Sis's success
than yours truly and I meant every word
including during the bad news storm on
Election night at the White House on
Trump brought more people into the party
and then expanded the base from those
blue collar workers on out uh so we'll
see what happens as the night goes
forward but to me Florida is the future
for the Republican
party but now my advice to them to
suspend their campaigns and unite behind
Trump comes from my deep concern about
what the future looks like if Biden
manages somehow to stay in power now
Republicans need to devote every minute
they have and every penny they have to
stopping the neo- marxists who've taken
over the Democrat Party and dropping out
to campaign for Trump also happens to be
the best thing for both of their
political Futures as well because if
they play their cards right and do it
right now they're going to be sitting
pretty for 2028 or
2032 they're both young enough and in
the case of DeSantis he's still the
second most popular Republican in the
United States of
America now it's always tough after all
the hard work that candidates put in to
finally admit that this is not their
time but that's politics and by the way
political consultants and you know who
you are the paid people they get paid
very well they tell candidates all too
often what those candidates desperately
want to hear you can turn this around
boss don't look at the numbers well
theirs is one of the few professions
where you're actually rewarded for
failing but in the real world Americans
see their country disappearing and in
the real GOP Grassroots they want Trump
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere
else